The prophet Muhammad sallallah.aihi
wasallam told us that whoever builds a
mosque for Allah, Allah will build for
him a sim at a house in Jenna. And we
know the great reward that will not only
be gained but rather will fill your
grave after your death. Whenever someone
prays there, whenever someone gives
shahada in the masid, whenever someone
learns something in the masid, yes, that
will be something that you'll have on
your scale.
[Music]
How are you guys doing?
the surviile and subordinate Patrick Bet
David, who is a professional apple
polisher and shoe shiner for the likes
of Netanyahu,
who had him on wearing an ingratiating
smile, trying to appease him, trying to
humor him, trying to give him what he
wants. uh because he is a surviile man,
a subordinate, a pathetic, measly uh
individual who's uneducated actually uh
Google educated uh not just that but
WhatsApp alumni uh an individual who is
a Ponzi scheme expert. This time he
wanted to get someone a little bit more
IQ on a white nationalist race realist
farright individual called Nick Fuentes
who I've been trying to get in contact
with myself. I have, you know, I've been
through Sneo and through Myron Gaines
and all these kinds of things. And I'm
pretty sure he has received the message.
And there's I'm not challenging to obey.
I'm not trying to harm anybody. I'm not
trying to hurt anybody. I'm not trying
to I'm not trying to I just want to
talk. I mean, there's nothing to be
afraid of this, you know, it's just a
discussion, just a little have we can
have fun. We can have talk about your
white nationalist views. You can talk
about immigration, talk about Islam,
talk about Christianity, talk about
whatever you like to talk about,
but it hasn't uh been a favorable reply
yet. Hopefully will be soon. Yet, Mr.
David had this individual on and this is
what he had to uh say. Let's look at
this clip and come back and respond in
kind.
>> Which of the two do you think has been a
bigger net positive to America?
Oh well, it has to be Israel.
Absolutely.
>> Okay. So, so, so a part about that that
part
>> but well in terms of I wouldn't say net
positive. I would say in terms of raw
maybe like gross positive because
they've had a lot of contributions
culturally and even you know in terms of
uh art, literature, music also
scientifically
but it's difficult to say on that
because I also think that there's quite
a bit of a detriment. I think that the
melting pot comes from the Jewish
community. What do you mean by that?
>> The idea of the melting pot that comes
from a Jewish playwright,
you know, because Jewish people come to
America and and like all immigrants,
they say, well, we want America to be
more welcoming. So, they start to spin
up these ideas that, well, America was
never this country of white Christians.
It's always been a melting pot for all
immigrants. They want the country to be
more open because that makes it more
comfortable for them. It makes it more
tolerant for them. But this has also
made us more open and tolerant for
Muslims for example.
We're bringing I mean who's been the
biggest driver of like the Heartellar 65
immigration act. It was like the SPLC
which was run by Jewish lawyers. And so
they're major drivers of mass migration.
They're also major drivers of the
pro-Israel politics like the Iraq war.
It was many Jewish journalists and and
pundits and advocates.
>> Sure. So a point being is like when you
calculate on net and I agree with you
like I think there are a lot of people
that are critical of Israel that are
reluctant to acknowledge the good that
Jews do and I think that Jews are
they're brilliant. Many of them are
brilliant. So, so, so when I'm saying
net positive, I'm talking jobs, economy.
How often you hear about crime, what
they do? Like, if you have a choice
between living in a city in Minnesota,
Dearbornne,
>> and living in, I don't know what's the
biggest city. What's the city that Boca
Raton, let's just say, right?
>> Uh, uh, uh, if you have a choice between
raising your family between Dearbornne
and Boca Raton, where do you choose?
>> Boca Raton.
>> Okay. So, so
they go to a place and by the way to me
if that was Muslims I would say Muslims
but statistically wherever they live
it's safer things are nicer things get
better.
>> I agree.
>> And that that is one part to measure
where they're at. Now
>> uh do I see uh them uh overly
aggressive? Do I see them the type that
are going to use politicians and buy
them like Marjorie Taylor Green and
other people are saying? 100%. Do I see
them they're going to be there in
everyone's DM and email saying, "Hey,
you know, we'd love to support you. We'd
love to bring you to Israel and you
know, doing all that stuff." It's
obvious. I'm seeing it myself. Okay.
>> Do I look at that and shame them and
say, "Oh, you shame on I look at that
and say, "No, I wish Armenians would do
that. I've never gotten an invitation
from Prime Minister of Armenia. he
should probably send me an invite to go
there, right? It's not a bad idea to
come and show the country. I'm Armenian.
I'm a Syrian. Syrians don't have a
country. It's probably a good idea. You
don't see that. You wish others would do
that. So, for me, as much as when I go
into that uh do, by the way, I'll give
you one other side that uh you know,
Israel's going to be like, "Yeah, yeah,
yeah." This other side to me is I
actually do believe they leverage MSAD
to get intel. I actually do believe they
use blackmail. I actually do believe
they do that. So,
you know, so, oh, there's nothing going
on with Epstein. No, no, no. I Michael
Wolf did a podcast with him two months
ago, and when he was at Epstein's house,
the 100 hours of recording that he has
with him, I said, "How many times would
Ew beard there?" Uh, uh, am I saying his
name correctly? Barack Barack. He said
he was there many times. He saw Bill
Gates there many times. Why would the
former prime minister visit the guy 30
something times? Just because the
conversation's great. That's a little
bit suspect, right? So you see in the
beginning guys he's making this
comparison and he's saying what is more
beneficial essentially to America who
have been more beneficial Israel net
benefit or is it the Muslims okay and
then Nick Fuentes he kind of answers in
one direction then he goes back on his
word you'd think that you know he's
marketing himself as a very high IQ
individual that he'd have a coherent and
cogent reply he's the white man he's a
race realist he should have according to
him a greater to IQ's than all of us.
You should know about all these things.
I mean, why you have to keep changing
your mind and changing your opinions?
Anyway, I first and foremost, I mean,
it's not a neutral standing point in the
first place, is it? If you're saying
that what's more beneficial to the
United States of America, you're not
asking a question like, for example,
what's bene more beneficial to
humankind? If the assumption is that
that which is beneficial to the United
States of America is that which is good.
And that is a contested assumption for
obvious reasons. I mean these are people
that came into a country, decimated the
indigenous uh rendered them
subordinates, oppressed them in more
ways than one and through concepts like
manifest destiny and westward expansion
took over the entire continent and made
it what it is today which to be honest
is not a bastion of whatever you think.
It's a bastion of an ideal place, a
utopia. It's nothing of the sort. It's a
place where poverty relative and
absolute is rife. It's a place where gun
crime is repugnant. I mean, it's
something which is so widespread. But
that's another issue for another day.
Even not withstanding all of these false
assumptions that undergur your
questioning
what you don't understand
and what you have failed to grasp
because of your pebb brain ponzi scheme
brain can't grasp it you see you should
have used Google for this one is that
Israel as a country and Muslims are a
group of religious people and so
therefore it's not a like forlike
comparison I mean what would have been a
more sophisticated or normal kind of
comparison would be to compare Israel
with a Muslim majority country and if
you're talking about Jews anyway are we
talking about their treatment because he
goes on to talk about where is a safer
place etc where Muslims are versus where
Jews are are we including the
settlements in that are we including the
cities that have a an Arab population in
so-called Israel proper are we including
Gaza in that where it was settled until
2005 what are we including in your
parameters? So you have to manipulate
and shift the goalpost in order to get
the answers that you want to get. But
even if we notwithstanding once again we
we give it all to you no problem. A net
benefit when you're doing a cash flow
forecast which is something maybe you're
more familiar with or maybe you
outsource that just like you do your
masculinity and just like you do your
dignity and you subcontract that. If you
had used your mind boy Yeah. If you had
both of you used your minds a little
bit, then you would have thought, okay,
how much does the United States of
America give to Israel per year? Oh,
they give about four billion do they or
how many years have they done that for?
And is that just what we see? Not
including all the weapons they've given
them and all this kind of things for all
of their escapades when they're
attacking a militia militia and a group
a militant group and they've been doing
so since 200 whatever it is. In fact,
really since the 80s because that's when
they were accepted.
So, is that a good use of your money?
The white man, the American Nick
Fuentes, is that an excellent use of
your money? Is that a net benefit for
you? Now, I know I have to give you
credit. You've been pro Palestine a lot
of the time and you have condemned, you
know,
Israel and all these kind of things, but
this kind of answer is pathetic. And we
understand what your agenda is. you're a
white nationalist and you're trying to
promulgate,
espouse or otherwise promote a white
nationalist agenda. You're trying to
make it look like we're the backwards
individuals who are low IQ, all these
kinds of things. But once again, if you
feel comfortable and you feel safe and
you feel confident
about those kinds of things, then why
don't we have a discussion?
We have a discussion. Okay. Once again,
I'm not intending to do anything or to
humiliate you or this and that and the
other. I'm not trying to do. Don't worry
about this. You're in safe hands. Ask
sne very good, very kind individual. No
problem.
If you're confident, if you're not
confident, then really you should stop
speak about Islam and Muslims. You
haven't even spoken to a Muslim who is
like, you know, a traditionalist. You
haven't even spoken to them. So why do
you keep speaking about them and you
don't have the courage to speak to them?
Well, that's going to be on your record
and that's all I have to say.
Hey, you are you wasting your time on
social media again? Your brothers and
sisters in Islam net from Norway are
establishing a masid, a da center.
Establishing a masid to convey the
message of Islam is one of the best
deeds a Muslim can do. There's a huge
need for it in Norway. You know this and
I know this. So that makes the reward
even greater. So give generously and
Allahel will give you even more.